ergo Bret Baier hopefully we're going to
play a new oculus rift game today called
lost in the rift not alone in the rift I
don't know if this the same guy who made
it but you can use to hide us and you
can use oculus and that's good enough
for me to want to play it so that's the
way okay it's definitely by the same
maker cuz okay I will be shifting I've
been sitting hello oh look at that tent
it's so cute now look at that little
basket that is not even a basket I don't
know what I'm talking about
damn this is some jet trees the fighting
me goddamn trees yeah god I hate camping
what the [ __ ] am I doing here sit oh oh
oh how convenient I camped outside this
rock thingy ah get away from me drinks
oh why is it getting darker there's this
slender London I don't need your notes I
don't want to date you
I thought we'd been over this oh [ __ ]
margin is what it says but don't bounce
on my face paper I've been it's been
four days since I saw her last days Anna
just come home and it wake up from this
shut off a note the you don't know
Howard you wet anyway
anyway okay let's go over here this is
pretty [ __ ] cool
I'm miss playing with the oculus I've
been cheating on here I feel bad ah
don't [ __ ] with me trees pockets printed
[ __ ] haha what was that what was that
pull this out there I'm not afraid
I'm panic I I'm no known YouTube for not
being oh wait oh it's just sit down
there I'm the [ __ ] freedom I ain't
afraid of those Thunder jeez
ah [ __ ] alright I don't know why I'm
running but we're doing it another stone
but the [ __ ] are you doing how's that
gosh the [ __ ] Thunder is scaring me
I'm such a [ __ ] yeah another stun we
should get sounded haha not funny okay
Oh jump over there over there
did you bros hear that that is so creepy
that is still [ __ ] creepy okay my cue
stone I swear to god it was blue before
another British Jack I have the worst
goose bump ever seriously this is so
unreal all the body was to do it what's
the cab second
alone in the forest Jesus Christ
that's my only request in life half in
peace please put that on my gravestone f
AP that weight fib yes that's right
Wow who is that there you want to fight
me please I heard something well I guess
we have no choice
Jeff not after that oh you know what oh
look at the time oh I have a dental
appointment I'm sorry I have to get out
of this [ __ ] forest if only I knew
where to go oh god oh god you're out
there aren't you oh god oh god oh god oh
god oh god oh god oh god oh god oh god
it's gonna be fine tips it's all again
the big game oh no it's not gonna be
good I didn't what is this oh no oh no
oh
they'd never make this is a mean man oh
I'm sure it's fine it's just
Oh what happened what happened
okay I'm going go Alvin please exit be
quarters you know what an exit would be
[ __ ] nice and I'm into the music ha
ha ha ha hello I'm a Swedish man I never
heard a soul except that one squirrel
but he made me birds of night I knew
that [ __ ] would come back to me
I told my mom what the [ __ ] was that
sound okay that's all I got
okay what is this a psychiatrist those
fascist of trying to get me out of their
way they want to lock me up again want
to pump that venom in my things again
okay okay well you know what
[ __ ] happens get over it you [ __ ]
Merrill's can I swing at you huh I'm
great stopping you right now see how
that feels like okay wow I thought I saw
something okay
don't worry it's just a game there are
unicorns probably somewhere hidden and
big titties okay it seems like I need it
of course we need a job I'll see y'all
missing job nothing I'm not even joking
when I turn around and think there's
something behind me it literally makes
me want to [ __ ] out my intestines okay I
get a game I got it you want me to go to
quarters I get it
as a wise man once said Yolo I mean
no one whites ever said okay okay it's
fine
oh great we're going more down that's
what I was hoping for a dead end no way
you can go left to the left to the left
everything you own
there better be chocolate down here a
sweet chocolate stop coming man you make
me look fat okay I got a rep on YouTube
oh wait we go well what was that no no
no no no no no no what happened what
happened it's this gas this is gas I
don't understand the problem I don't
understand it oh that could be a raccoon
oh no that's just it's a squirrel he's
coming back Bob a breast I don't think I
can recall any time that I've been this
[ __ ] afraid
in a video game my heart is beating like
a bum no [ __ ] drum on don't sell okay
it's gonna be okay it's gonna be okay
I it's gonna be okay it's gonna be okay
are we got we're going more done yeah
yeah yeah it's gonna be all right
[Music]
how much [ __ ] further down to the man
go before he wants to wear the thumb
wait wait a second coolers that could be
in the wind that could be anything the
office
[Music]
our luck we're going to the office
maybe there's a nice little present over
here
Oh [ __ ] me she nice
oh my god hot Chili's I didn't know all
those her hands I will okay
her everything can take a step back
you'll never leave this place I'll shut
up note oh god damn it what what what oh
I'm somebody smart someone give me a
smarty that doesn't make sense
[Music]
I don't want to do that again I don't
want to do it [ __ ] you you know get me a
fix
not today not today
No
not today
oh hi I think we did it
access
oh go be gentle be gentle be gentle be
gentle with me
be gentle with my poor nipples I'm so
lonely i´m mr. lonely I have nobody
[Music]
what the [ __ ] are you doing hey hey it's
okay it's okay it's okay you keep oh but
but now but now is it over
please be over
[Music]
that was that was incredible
and he didn't even have jump scares and
it affected me so much do you [ __ ]
see this and that was amazing seriously
I I was incredible I don't know what to
say but you probably you probably didn't
experience exactly the same as I did the
more horror games are gonna be made for
the oculus when games are made for the
oculus it's it's [ __ ] disturbing how
how freaky it is I really like what it
did with this one cuz he built tension
all the way through for 30 minutes and
he didn't it didn't even live up to
anything but still skin [ __ ] outta me
anyway let me like enjoyed watching it
subscribe to come with me I'll see in
the next month